hello there has been more fighting
overnight in Sudan where rival forces
remain locked in a power struggle
despite international calls for a
ceasefire
the U.N says more than 180 people have
been killed in more than three days of
fighting between the Sudanese Army and
the nation's largest paramilitary Force
nearly 2 000 people have been injured in
the capital Khartoum and other regions
the un's envoy to Sudan says the warring
parties are not open to talks hospitals
homes and power stations have been
shelled and we have satellite images
that show the extensive destruction to
airports and government facilities
harthum International Airport has
sustained some of the worst damage from
the conflict at the airport which also
has a military Wing at least 20 aircraft
have been damaged that includes a mix of
Civilian and military fighter jets and
helicopters and at the Obed military Air
Base which also has a civilian Wing
those images show at least four
destroyed aircraft on the tarmac
including three fighter jets
well Sudan's Military Jets have been
bombing positions of the rapid support
forces at the marawi airport that's in
the north including a hangar at the air
base
and in the center of the capital
Khartoum smoke has been seen Rising
above the intelligence building the
Ministry of Education as well as a train
station let's bring in Hippa Morgan
who's joining us now from Khartoum
sohiba what's the situation like uh from
where you are
well it was a bit of a quiet night
around the central part of Hartung but
in uh but there was fighting in the
northern part of the capital as well as
in the uh Southern sides as well but in
the early hours of the morning we were
able to hear helicopters fighter jets
airstrikes being launched around the
vicinity of the presidential Palace and
around the vicinity of the general
command of the army so it looks like
both sides are trying to Rifle control
of these positions the rapid support
forces released a footage showing their
presence inside hartum international
airport it's not clear when this was
taken and who has control of the airport
at the moment that's one of the points
of struggle between the two sides
civilians in parts of uh Khartoum report
seeing tanks on the streets and that
they can still hear the heavy artillery
being fired and that they can see the
combats ongoing between the rapid
support forces and the Sudanese Army so
it's clear that on the fourth day of the
fighting this battle is continuing to
take place in many parts of the Capital
Khartoum and in the northern part of
marawi when you look at the other states
it looks to be relatively quiet so it
looks like most of the fighting is
focused in these two areas the northern
city of merui and in the capital of
Khartoum and here by the latest figures
we have are that 180 people have been
killed that's according to the UN
thousands injured as well how are
hospitals coping
well hospitals have reported that there
are some uh some of them that have been
hit and so they can't operate and give
medical assistance to those who are in
need but there are also doctors who
spoke to who say that the numbers are
reported of deaths and injuries is going
to be far less than the reality on the
ground because many people can't access
hospitals and many people can't seek
medical attentions and families have
been reporting their loved ones and
relatives missing so there's a question
of where are those people as well
they're quite concerned they say that
they're worried that their relatives and
loved ones may have been killed in the
fighting between the rapid support
forces and the Army but their bodies
cannot be retrieved because of the
situation on the ground Medics say they
can't count the dead they can't go out
they can't risk their lives because of
the situation then there are those who
are trapped for four days now with no
food and water many people did not
expect this fighting so they did not
store enough food and water for these
days and Khartoum is not a city prepared
for war despite the numerous conflicts
in Sudan there was never any direct
fighting between between armed groups
here in the capital so there are no
safety shelters people say they don't
know where to go for safety and this has
been the situation now for the past four
days okay but we'll let you go for now
thank you for bringing us that uh from
Khartoum we'll stick with heartum for a
moment and speak to Hamid khalafalah
who's a researcher and policy analyst
joining us from the capitol as well
thanks for speaking to us what's it like
from from a civilian point of view in
Khartoum right now
thank you uh this tuition this morning
uh continues to be uh very difficult uh
uh they were just listed as we were
speaking now uh identified them over in
uh above the residential areas obviously
specifically and and bombing actually uh
it's difficult to tell what it's
targeting uh for sure but there are
rapid support forces uh camps uh in
several areas in in khatum North so
perhaps this is what they're targeting
uh the continue so the fighting
continues uh as intensive as as it has
been on the other hand the humanitarian
yeah so how are people how are people
coping with all of this
yeah on that like I was just about to
say on the other hand the humanitarian
situation is getting very difficult
people are finding it very difficult to
to uh manage but I've seen the most
alarming thing is that people are
starting to run out of food because uh
water has been uh cut in many areas uh
around two uh since day one so this is
the fourth day today uh because the
water stations were damaged uh due to
the piping so in in many cases people
are just starting to run out of water
there's no water to buy at Shops uh
because shops that are offered are very
limited and they have also doubt all the
water that they have many of these
neighborhoods also don't have uh Power
and uh it's it's very difficult for
anyone uh to access medical care uh get
their uh you know medicines uh Supply
and so on right and and in so many cases
people have uh you know died either
because of the shooting or for other
other causes and so on and the families
have you know had to live with the
bodies uh in the houses with no weight
of accessing a mortgage or symmetry is
it clear to you right now who who has
the upper hand in the capital and who
controls the airport for example and how
do you see this situation developing
it's very difficult to tell who has the
upper hand uh we keep on receiving uh
information uh from different actors uh
contradict the information from uh
different actors uh this battle uh and
this fight to interact support forces
and his Armed Forces is not only one
that's on ground it's one it's very much
online uh they have been uh using uh a
lot of misinformation and disinformation
tactics uh since day one so it's very
difficult to tell for instance the
airport there is or there has been
evidence that the rapid support forces
uh was in control from different uh
eyewitnesses and videos and so on but
then you would also see some other uh
videos from the swimming down forces uh
suggesting otherwise so it's very
difficult to tell who actually has the
upper hand right and over the next few
days what do you think just uh over the
next few days how do you see this this
developing next few days next few weeks
what do you think is going to happen
so uh there isn't there aren't any signs
that any of the uh fighting forces are
willing to uh stop fighting anytime soon
but if they're not their tone has
changed I think yesterday a little bit
where they're showing a bit more open
the souls uh you know a ceasefire and
talks to what extent they are serious or
they're just saying that to please the
International Community we will have to
test uh and and see which I think the
International Community pushing to send
uh delegates uh to Fortune uh like the
egot pushing to send the heads of States
of uh the member states and so on that
would be very important uh and that
would be very useful because like I said
they are saying that they're open but we
can't trust them until we see that they
actually commit to a CS5 okay we'll have
to leave it there we thank you so much
for joining us from Khartoum